if you're a star Wars fan you'll be
happy to know that we've gotten our
hands on the battlefront 2 trailer early
I'm Tony in this game spot news update
comes from a galaxy far far away yes the
battlefront 2 trailer was leaked and it
confirms a lot of the reports we've
heard about the sequel the usual big
multiplayer battles are here but thanks
to some narration from a female soldier
we also get a few hints about what the
campaign mode will entail as for the
setting it seems that all star wars
errors are included with appearances
from Darth Maul Yoda ray and kylo Ren it
even looks like we'll get writable
tauntauns this time around finally the
trailer mentions some pre-order DLC
called Star Wars the last Jedi heroes
considering battlefront one received DLC
for both episode 7 and rogue one it
makes sense that battlefront two would
get some for episode 8 all of this was
supposed to come from the official
trailer at star wars celebration this
weekend so be sure to LIKE and subscribe
in case they show anything different
after this league star wars battlefront
2 is releasing on ps4 xbox one and pc
sometime this year considering the
alleged episode 8 tie in a release date
around the movie's premiere makes sense
but for more space shooting action right
now you can check out the highlights
from our Mass Effect Andromeda live
stream with kind of funnies Greg Miller